I want us to have a frontier in space I
want to live in the society that has a
frontier and if the only way to get that
is to build it that I'm going to build
it
[Music]
out in the middle of the Mojave Desert
you will find the Mojave spaceport right
off the runway is a company called XCore
aerospace and they have a vision for
what could be the world's first space
airliner this is Jeff Grayson one of
their co-founders like many born during
the Apollo era Jeff grew up believing it
was only a matter of time before mankind
spearheaded by NASA would begin
colonizing outer space I don't ever
remember not believing that there would
be a Frontier available to us in space I
don't ever remember not expecting that
I'd get to work in it there was this
thing that we now call the space shuttle
that was supposed to solve the space
transportation problem it is the worst
disaster in the history of the American
space program and President Reagan has
declared a week of mourning for the
seven astronauts who lost their lives on
their way into space this morning not
only had NASA known about that problem
and not fixed it they had known about
lots of other problems and not fixed
them and that was really the moment
where I said it doesn't matter how much
money Congress does or doesn't give NASA
this agency is not going to get me off
this planet
so I sat down and started writing
business plans
the way to make money and space
transportation is a way to make money in
any other kind of transportation it's
called the Southwest or alliance model
you keep the wheels in the wheel well
every minute that is not in the air is a
minute wasted how fast can we fly how
quick can we turn it around how few
people can we take to turn it around it
was a really cool idea but before they
could go and get investors they had to
prove that they could actually build a
spaceship year after year they kept
plugging away showing the world that
they knew rides each success brought
them a little bit closer towards their
goal of building the spaceship but
they're calling the Lynx mark one on
average NASA's shuttle travel to space
about four times a year the Lynx is
designed to go to space four times a day
we want transportation to and from orbit
to be cheap reliable and frequent enough
so that all of these things people dream
about in space can actually happen they
can't happen right now because the cost
is too high the risk is too high and you
have to wait too long for your chance to
fly but because it can do it with such a
small ship and because we can fly that
small ship so frequently cost of doing
each flight gets to be very low
my son was probably four or five when he
looked at me one night and said you know
daddy is it really true that they used
to go to the moon when you're a boy it's
really frightening that that question
could even be asked that's what a dark
age is that our cage is not when you
have forgotten how to do something it's
when you forgot that you could people
look at things like going to the moon
and they don't even know that that's a
thing that can be done we did do them we
can do them we just have to decide to do
them
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh